contemplate
things at plan so if things plan
they have to have
um an ability to simulate the future
that because they have to simulate or
represent at some elemental level the
consequences of their action upon the
world
and if they have now the capacity to
represent something that has not yet
happened namely in the future then they
now have the capacity to represent
counter factual outcomes so i think the
the meta hard problem
inherits simply because we have a
sufficiently
temporally deep generative model
that can represent the consequences of
our actions and of course using the word
our
implies
some kind of elemental agency and some
kind of self-worth because it's only me
that's doing the acting and the
consequences of my action not your
action uh so so
in in that sense i think that the hard
problem um
sort of pales into into insignificance
in relation to the meta problem of why
it is that we have philosophers
can i pursue that just a little bit
i think you raise an extraordinarily
interesting point here carl
and so i want to ask you
from a phylogenetic perspective
um
do you think that
organisms
that can plan
necessarily
are able to represent multiple
counterfactuals
so let's give an example
suppose you're a cheetah chasing a
gazelle
you're planning your moves
while looking at the gazelle's moves
and your objective is success
do you think that the cheetah worries
about the other counterfactual condition
where the gazelle isn't caught
or does it just represent this one
counterfactual condition that is in a
sense the goal state
i think that's an excellent question i
personally think that
and when i answer these questions i
think how would i simulate this how
would i put a cheater in silico and
integrate um according to the
differential equations that must be
present under certain assumptions
and my guess is that the cheetah chasing
the gazelle would as you say just be
pursuing a path of least action and it
would not have an explicit
representation of alternative paths so
it would be responding in the moment in
a reflexive habitual way so that's a
really important question because
if we don't have or all of our behavior
is just a manifestation of pursuing
those paths of least resistance or
mathematically those you know paths of
station reaction
um then there is no counterfactual to
select from and there is no notion of
planning in the sense of i am going to
do this as opposed to that
but that doesn't mean to say biological
organisms um don't have the capacity to
um plan multiple futures and i'll just
give you one real simple example of um
your our brains and i would imagine even
the brains of reptiles to a certain
extent um
being able to plan multiple um
actions in the future and that's in eye
movements so if i just take one of the
simplest problems in terms of planning
or perhaps not the simplest but one of
the um
the the the problems of planning that
have to be resolved within um
you know several hundred milliseconds
given that we have to choose where to
look every 250 milliseconds in order to
gather the right kind of information to
make you know to construct the scene in
which we are situated and coming back to
your preoccupation chris yo you know how
on earth do we then explain these sparse
um
circadic samples
within some frame of reference and
space-time sort of how do we you know
sense make with reference to some
constructs such as space and time but
the point i'm making here
is that the anatomy of um
many
brains many phenotypes
does have the capacity to represent the
consequences of looking everywhere at
the same time at once before they have
looked so these are sort of sometimes
referred to as salience maps and we know
that um there are good candidates for
these salience maps for example the deep
layers of the superior colliculus and
what could have argue uh possibly some
anatomy of the pulvina so if you look at
the um
if you like the neuronal encoding of the
salience of
where
the salience of the next place to look
what's going to grab my attention
and make that be manifest overtly with
an eye movement to go and look over
there
then there you can interpret i think the
anatomy the oculomotor system and
especially the um
that which underlies uh circadian
movements as entertaining
a whole range possibly millions of
potential um
plans of action and the consequences and
then the brain literally selects the one
that's most likely uh which you can
simulate by doing bump attractors on
these sort of salience maps or
representations of the the salience of
the epistemic affordance or the expected
information again if i looked over here
and over here and
you select that your eyes jump over
there and off you go again so i think
it's a great question and in a sense
speaks i think to a certain extent to
what mike was alluding to before that
there are certain
setups or a certain sort of neuronal
electrochemical
infrastructures
out there
that can be read
as just pursuing passively such action
in a reflexive way
and there are others that may have this
um richer structure this deeper
structure that could be uh support the
you know the the the active sentence and
the sort of what i i'm reading now is
cognition if cognition entails planning
uh that i certainly think there has to
be an act of selection in play here um
selection what does that mean from
something from what well multiple
alternatives and then we come back to
the central notion of this this counter
factual
mike is that what you had in mind in
terms of breaking this sort of uh pan
psychism uh sort of trap you know the
different kinds of
self-organization
yeah i mean that's certainly certainly
related you know uh the thing the thing
that um and and so i agree with chris's
kind of uh gut feeling on this i find it
very difficult to imagine cognition
without some sort of awareness or or
simple consciousness however what what
strikes me as
different than real about the hard
problem is that unlike all the quote
unquote easy problems and maybe unlike
the meta hard problem we kind of know
the format or the shape of answers to
those questions right they're either
they're numbers of their equations or
their lists of capacities you know we we
know what what a proper answer would
look like and yet i i find it very hard
to imagine if we if somebody claimed to
have a
a good theory of consciousness and i
were to ask them okay well what is the
prediction of your theory in this
particular case i don't know what the
format of the answer looks like because
numbers and the typical things we get
don't do the trick they you know they're
sort of third-person descriptions and so
so is the answer does the answer come in
the form of a poem is it art is it you
know something you have to literally
plug yourself into to then have that
experience like what's the i i find it
different because i don't know what if
we had a true a correct theory i don't
know what that theory would output you
know unlike for all these other theories
where at least we have some idea of what
the output looks like
well that's that's a better answer to
the hard problem then that's the that's
very good
before
i'm sure the answer is quantum physics
and that's that's what it's going to
look like if we could if we could
understand it the answer would be in
quantum physics